you see my girl Doris Burke what's her
name is that her name what is her name
your girl no who is your girl dude
I said it I was like that sounds weird
[Music]
welcome back everybody to an awesome
episode of the careful boys where today
Steve is wearing the same episode as
last time I'm not wearing the same
outfits last time you need to wear pants
but it's like chain is way bigger I
wasn't I never wore the gold the gold
tiger suit how many outfits you don't
wear the gold tiger suit with this last
time I did not I'm selling me I'm
messing up my Steve outfits I have nine
of them now nine wow like nine full my
nine in my tracksuits how many from
Amazon all every every one every single
one that's cool and you know what sucks
about the news now is I was gonna get
Balenciaga eventually
oh dude that was my goal attraction yeah
and now you can still they're probably
real cheap right now you guys real cheap
yeah it's a little weird yeah they fired
the photographer or something or the
creative director because it was their
idea or did something no they try to
blame the set director
let's see what they did decorator they
took a bunch of pictures with kids
holding like bondage Bears yeah BDSM
outfit and they apologize but the thing
is people dug even further and in the
photo shoots they're like oh it wasn't
really about that but in the photo
shoots right there's like this one lady
that's chilling on in front of a desk
and there's books about pedophilia the
[ __ ] court cases in the full files
that if you zoom in their court case is
about pedophilia so it's like clearly
[ __ ] this was geared for that
[ __ ] like Lolita it's a good theme
it's a good theme why not right but then
and then they made another apology right
and then they try to blame the [ __ ]
set decorator and not the creative
director and that's why they're mad
because they're like the create director
is [ __ ] way more responsible than the
[ __ ] yeah do you think the creative
director sees like Fahrenheit 451 like
what the [ __ ] is this doing in here this
is a pedophilia shoot get this [ __ ]
book out of here opposite mad this is
what happens when when clothing brands
get too successful they're like hey
let's just try to like make pedophilia
cool
we can make kids sexier I guess that was
the next step because their last one was
very like derelict right remember when
like yeah it's like homeless yeah it was
like very homeless Chic right
everything's coming out and you're
you're starting to be like even if
you're into fashion you're starting to
be like this kind of derelict this is
kind of trash how close were you to
being like I'm gonna commit because I
know you're the you're aside from Steve
you're the most stylish guy do you have
Balenciaga stuff no not after the pay
cut yeah that's true that was the first
thing to go you don't have money to
spend for like a 1200 I don't have a 19
million dollar you know valuation online
yeah like Ryan that's not in Balenciaga
no that's in oil
no it's a Commodities never never had a
Balenciaga Ryan's a Saudi Prince bro
that's what he really is I mean deep
down you are he doesn't want oil money
huh he he does look like he does look
like he's never stressed about a dollar
a day
he sits there like this someone looks
like that yeah dude well he also looks
like speaking of Saudi princes so I
don't know I just found out my mom has a
godson and I don't even know she had a
God Son wait what wait
isn't the Saudi Prince oh okay the
godson is like part of the hospitality
team at the win and so he sees [ __ ]
crazy Ballers all the time and one of
them is a Saudi Prince and so he told my
mom the story where when they come to
the casino they first have a meeting so
they have a meeting with all the staff
and he'll literally go here's three
million dollars I'm tipping everyone
first so every single staff member in
the entire Hotel gets three to four G's
like that and then he goes now I'm here
you guys know how to treat me oh
the most baller [ __ ] ever dude that's
[ __ ] can you imagine I would just run
in front of that guy to beat his
Carpenter
you can walk on me sir yeah yeah all you
need to cover right here right
I was like damn that's [ __ ] crazy
you never watched the footprint off no
yeah I don't know me tipping three to
four G's what's the most baller [ __ ] you
guys have done that's what this video
has turned into that's what this video
is saying totally yeah I went to a
course I didn't know yeah well you did I
went to Noodle planet and I got two
plates oh noodle Planet beef Pad Thai
and the beef steak one okay one time I
was in Bali real high baller okay let me
tell you something I was at a wedding
with my family there was like 12 of us
everybody got [ __ ] two plates
everyone got a drink a coffee smoothie
yeah bro everyone's eating there was 12
of us I paid 80 in the U.S what the [ __ ]
I was like I'm a baller bro I was like I
didn't know I was so rich like I just
felt like Anthony Lee sit in Courtside
oh so that so you guys go next whoever's
gonna top that go ahead oh you know good
luck one time I bought a
um a picture of a monkey for six grand
it's a picture of a dragon egg but the
best part is that maybe it will turn
into another picture
did it ever evolve I think it's probably
dead though yeah can't even get the file
they unplugged it we're not Mother of
Dragons here's the disaster part of any
project when they're like we're gonna
open source it it's up to the community
now now it's like oh Jesus
what about your Courtside experience
that's crazy I've never sat Courtside
how did you get that yeah how the [ __ ]
did you get that man it's not in the
baller category because I didn't pay for
it but you know thanks bbgo USA can't
wait to join you guys who the [ __ ] wait
you're chilling with bbgo is that a
Ramen company no it's a Korean come on
let them know let them know Nick we're
trying to get adreads baby girl is a big
deal what I thought BB was like a a
designer for like 15 year old girls also
that b-e-b b-e-b-e
[Laughter]
oh BB go the 92nd right here
I love those what's that it's like the
Korean yeah I see those at Costco yeah
yes yes that's the one yeah the you know
sponsors of the [ __ ] are you chilling
with BB go guys you chill with your
competitor are they like lobbying you
these guys are eating you whole yeah
dude specifically
they're taking your whole company and
they're gonna get some sauce and like
they're trying you out
oh no they uh they hooked it up
um had uh me and a guest so I took my
cousin because I knew he would bust a
nut going out there we went Courtside to
the recent Lakers Pacers game so you
guys saw that post that I put up we were
leading you know there was a point where
we're up by like 17 points or some [ __ ]
just like leading the whole time Russell
was doing and staying where it's always
flipping a coin whether or not he's
actually gonna do something amazing
um but he's cocky as [ __ ]
uh and everything looked like it was
gonna be great and I remember just like
imagine my cousin but I do wouldn't it
be like such a wild game if like we just
still lost something that's why you
can't say [ __ ] like that you always
drink [ __ ] all the time it's always my
fault it's yeah it's 100 my fault I
can't believe you did that yeah it's
telling me sorry slapping your cousin
like I will never lose this game
I was wondering I was like how do you
get quartzite and it's like oh against
the Pacers I mean they give those
[ __ ] tickets away
my whole [ __ ] life I haven't seen him
do anything ever like they give those
tickets away yeah it was it was scripted
everybody knew that we were gonna get
owned which is why all the people left
Courtside they just left me and my
cousin there if you get a car wash at
Indianapolis with the wax they'll give
you a Pacers too
car novel waxes the one with the wax
though
was the game way different like like at
eye level you were so honestly I was I
was [ __ ] I was fully like um I was
Starstruck number one like where
Everything feels like when even when I'm
looking at Stu Lance who's like
reporting like six feet from me and they
all the cameras were right there and Stu
lands talking and me and my cousin are
like that's two Lance you see my girl
Doris Burke what's her name is that her
name what is her name your girl no who
is your girl
Doris isn't it right when I said it I
was like that sounds weird did you see
any celebrities sitting by you yeah
people so now Jack Nicholson was not
there it was Indiana you know not a real
fast
the Pacers yeah we'll skip it
are you close enough where like if Russ
ran by you could like give a little high
five well I feel like I could have
tripped the referee every [ __ ] time
he ran by the court we we [ __ ] felt
the floor shake we we [ __ ] heard them
cussing at each other like oh yeah yeah
Port talks people actually actually
talking [ __ ] or that's too easy
all the time every single time you don't
see on camera when like you know a
player will run up to the ref and still
try to just give him [ __ ] because he
knows that reps always make bad calls
and if they feel hella bad about it they
get called out on it they'll try to like
say a call in your favor the next time
yeah yeah yeah she's like politics yeah
just just seeing that like that type of
[ __ ] happened just seeing like
technicals get called out of nowhere you
know what I mean but actually being
aware of like how or why it started that
kind of stuff is like totally different
What's um what's the cash value of that
seat you were in by the way I looked it
up and uh they were going anywhere from
like 2500 or 4 000
500 to 4 000 I thought it'd be like five
digits you could buy like two monkey
pictures
by a couple of monkey pictures five
digits for floor seats maybe for two of
them
oh yeah but uh that again Indiana Pacers
so they're giving them away
yeah yeah and you see everything you
really see like even um it's so close
that uh you don't see the the like the
stats
oh yeah you're looking up you're trying
to be like how many how many fouls this
player have how many points does this
player have or whatever look it'll be
like I can't see [ __ ] or like when the
[ __ ] screen drops you know in the
very very beginning and they're like
playing stuff like you can't see it
because the screen's like here can they
tell that you don't belong in Courtside
us yes the two Asian guys who are
looking around and like trying to like
we're like trying to hold our piss and
not take breaks and stuff because you're
like taking pictures the whole time and
then and then there's like stereotypical
there's like richer white people on both
sides of us that like totally know each
other and they're like trying to like
say hi back and forth the whole time
they're like oh but it's like they
belong they're like Wahlburgers stole
his tickets again I got this [ __ ] guy
here plus like plus like I have to wear
the Jersey I have to wear the BB gun
Jersey as like part of the thing so I'm
sitting there with the jerseys but I
realize nobody who can Ford Courtside
wears jerseys they're not like those
kind of fans right right so I look like
a [ __ ] regular Asian boy Laker fan
sitting there that and I don't belong
loves baby girl you look like a
Make-a-Wish kid yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you want a charity
how are you feeling how's your symptoms
you think you'll make it to fourth
quarter that was a that was such an
exciting game too though because even
the guy at half court does the Wells
Fargo take a shot halftime thing for 75
grand and he made it
every and the crazy thing is last ice
game that had dude made it too the same
time yeah the same half court shot so
it's like how does he get picked twice
like that I don't know if it's the same
guy I'm just saying two half four shots
yeah yeah yeah but just just seeing like
at halftime the whole stadium [ __ ]
just erupts because like everybody's
shooting for the underdog right when
when there's a guy who's like trying to
go for a half question it's like 75 000
just sitting there with your buddy and
you're like dude it would be crazy to
make 75 what would you do with 75 second
yeah and then this full [ __ ] sinks it
and even the entire Laker bench was like
oh 80 ran up inside he like runs up and
high fives A.D and [ __ ] like Bear
Hugs him he's such [ __ ] hugging and
giving props to everybody in the Laker
bench we're like this is insane I love
that shot of you when the when the Pacer
started celebrating right next to it
you're all
dude you can see it on my [ __ ]
Instagram all of us are just like
there's no way we're gonna lose this
there's no way and then they [ __ ]
inbound it they missed the first one
Lakers are doing a shitty job getting
[ __ ] rebound they throw it over to
this young kid that [ __ ] LeBron has
been like really almost like you know
physically going off against the whole
game we're really trying to Punk it
looks like LeBron's trying to punk this
younger kid and his kids like not not
happening he's like trying his best he's
putting in the hustle the whole game
stopping LeBron a couple times in
different ways right whether it be a
foul or whatever you're not your old man
but right he is probably gold and then
and then he [ __ ] gets the ball at the
last second sinks his buzzer beat in
front of LeBron's face the whole bench
of the Pacers are up runs over and these
guys look like they're about to fall on
us you can see in my video I'm like
filming and then I have to go to 0.5
because it's too close dude and it it
just felt so like you the same thing the
whole Arena just goes silent and numb
for a solid like 12 seconds even
LeBron's like not having it he's like
looking at the scoreboard waiting for
officials to confirm the shot that clip
is crazy yeah it was just such an insane
moment but you guys get free tacos
though for losing yeah don't you guys
get free tacos if it's like above 100
points we're losing no you have to win
that's lame what's free tacos we're
talking about it's like some Laker games
after if if they score above 100 points
or something everyone in the stadium
gets free tacos
from Jack In The Box yeah Oh that's oh
still dope though still dope I like that
you gotta have that prepared
so you go to any Jack in the Box after
the game and then they give them a
ticket yeah dude you know how many jk
people spotted you you must have been in
like the perfect seat so many people
were sending messages like hey is this
Anthony is this Anthony you know who
sent a message asking if it was Anthony
the [ __ ] guy who was in Myanmar who
was trapped there he just got out he
escaped me and more and one of the first
thing he sends me is is this Anthony and
he was at the Laker game no he was
filming like a TV do you think he was
watching a legal stream
he was on three vpns yeah and he was
like I think I see Anthony dude I was
yeah it was it was fun I was getting
text messages with screenshots at the
back of my head how can we just throw
away that he escaped it's like yeah bro
yeah he made it out yeah that's what
he's like concerned about yeah we're
gonna get back to the Courtside thing
did you guys get home by the way it was
cool Steve did you get a hot dog
what the nachos like did you guys do
that story yeah
I got the carne asada fries and Corners
that sucked oh he ran he actually got
out well when we did the story he wasn't
out yet but he gave us a bunch of themes
of like this is how the news is showing
it and this is how it really is he's
also a doctor right yeah he's a doctor
yeah but he but he's out now and but
then he's trying to stay out but the
hard thing is he was saying that a lot
of countries won't let him stay there
because they don't want me and more
people well I went to some
um Pro Myanmar uh messaging boards and I
found out that he was giving us a lot of
disinformation
roll me and Marvin
there's a lot because he wants to be
balanced and see both sides trying to
get all the story the whole get the
inside scoop you know he's heavy in the
Myanmar scene
official sources just oh you went to the
Burma's the word.com
it's like they're cracked they're
cracked oh [ __ ]
yeah so back to the Courtside uh Fiasco
hey bro
um so quick story I I was working at
downtown LA at this office and there was
this very nice lady named Cheryl who's
like who wants to go sit Courtside of
the Clippers game I'm like I've never
been to a [ __ ] NBA game hell yeah I'm
gonna go Courtside right so then um
she's like okay cool all you have to do
is you take this yellow envelope and you
walk it to this booth and then you just
tell them that you're there to pick up
the tickets am I [ __ ] tight so I got
my buddy Andy and he's like this [ __ ]
he's like the whitest dude I know if you
guys think I'm white like this guy's
like [ __ ] full Aryan white like
shaved head yeah blue eyes like to go
white swastika from Boston like he's a
mass hole so so then so then um we get
there and we show up and I I open the
envelope and I'm and they're like oh
you're here like who are you here with I
was like oh let me just open this up and
it's like
I'm like I'm I'm here with the United
Negro College Fund what the [ __ ] go away
yeah wait because Cheryl was a black
lady at work and she was I guess she had
these tickets from uncf that
um that two whites collection she was
supposed to give away well she was gonna
go she was gonna go but then she she
didn't she wasn't able to go she was
doing something with her cat or some
[ __ ] so then I'm like I didn't I didn't
even read it I was just like
here's how here's how Wild
here's how Wild this is so either they
told Cheryl they're like you're gonna go
get sick Courtside and then
um when she shows up surprise your dog
Courtside you're all the way the [ __ ]
back which is what happened I'm
expecting to go Courtside they've set us
nosebleed all the way at the [ __ ] top
and like the worst seat is like when
you're sitting behind the hoop I was all
the way behind the hoop like on that
side on that side wow you can see the
half court shots do you think they
switched your ticket I have no idea
either they switch my tickets they're
like who are you with you know do you go
college phone they're like [ __ ] this guy
no you're not [ __ ] this guy yeah no idea
no idea but that was wild but you
already messed up the instructions she
said just hand them the envelope well no
they said who are you with because they
want they have they have a bunch of free
tickets but they don't know who you're
with it's just been like Aryan white guy
yeah it's the best should have been like
the Irish Club oh that's gorgeous the
IRA yeah hey Martin have you ever seen
the NBA game
before
[Laughter]
hahaha